تضييق الخناق على وسائل الإعلام في
باكستان لم يسبق له مثيل ، وهو أحد أفضل
الصحفيين الاستقصائيين لدينا في باكستان
أرشد شريف ، اغتيل في
كينيا قبل أسبوعين فقط ،
وكان هذا الرجل يفضح هذه المؤامرة التي
وقعت ضدي والتي تم
ملاحقتها في باكستان.  انتهى به الأمر بالذهاب
إلى دبي من هناك وذهب إلى كينيا
حيث قُتل هناك اثنان من
مساعدي المقربين أحدهما كان من قبل رئيس
الأركان أحدهما كان السناتور عزام سواثي
وكان كلاهما مع ابنة عارية عارية
وكلاهما ألقى باللوم على ضابط المخابرات الكبير أه
من كان مسؤولاً عن
التعذيب أخذوا ثلاث رصاصات من
رجلي اليمنى
أه اليسرى كانت بها شظايا
تركوها بالداخل أه
تضررت عظامي لذا رجلي في جبيرة
وربما سيستغرقني أربعة ستة أسابيع
وأربعة  إلى ستة أسابيع لأستأنف نشاطي المعتاد
منذ حوالي شهرين ، تم تصور هذه المؤامرة
أه ذهبت علنًا في 24
سبتمبر ، لقد أعلنت بالفعل
عن هذه المؤامرة ودعنا  أنا فقط
أعطيك الخلفية كيف أعرف
أن ما أقوله وما هو الدليل الذي
لدي بدأ عندما تم
إقصائي من الحكومة
منذ ذلك الحين
وما كان متوقعًا هو أن حزبنا
سينهار فقط في  حقيقة ما حدث
هو أن هاتين العائلتين
تم فرضهما علينا مرة أخرى اللذان حكمنا لمدة 30
عامًا ، وكان هناك رد فعل جماهيري كبير
، وبالتالي فبدلاً من نزول حركتي أو
حزبي إلى أسفل ، كان
هناك حزبان عمليان في مثل هذا
الدعم العلني نحن  يريدون 75 بالمئة
من الإنتخابات الفرعية أه منذ خروجنا عن
السلطة ولذا كل الجهود كانت بعد ذلك
لإخراجي من السباق
لإقصائي إرهابي أه أه
متهم بالإرهاب وهكذا بتهم مختلفة